Speaker 1: There is some very, very bad news for
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis. His approval is
collapsing as the Anti-woke movement is in a
freefall in the United States. So let's back
it up. I already told you that Anti-woke may be
a very silly approach to the 2024 presidential
campaign, and we are seeing loss after loss
after loss for the Anti-woke movement in the
last ten days On the program, I told you a judge
has blocked the Florida ban on gender affirming
care for trans youth says not going to stand.
Tennessee's anti drag bill has been blocked.
Gay marriage is as popular as ever in the United
States. Utah's book ban backfired and led to the
Bible being banned in some schools and the Book
of Mormon under consideration for a ban. And now
we learn that Ron DeSantis approval rating has
collapsed. As Newsweek reports, Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis has seen his approval rating fall
dramatically. Two weeks after announcing his
2024 presidential bid, according to online polling
company, Civics is dynamic approval rating graph.
DeSantis currently has a net approval rating
of -19. That means 55% disapprove, 36 approve.
That's -19. The data shows DeSantis has a major
unfavorable rating from those 18 to 34 women,
African-Americans, and importantly, the Hispanic
Latino population of Florida. In comparison,
he was even he was 4747 approval disapproval
in early December. So 4747 means zero, right?
5536 means -19. This is potentially very bad
for DeSantis. Not only would it be great.
To see DeSantis humiliated in 2024. From
the perspective of the presidential race,
and much of that is bigger than DeSantis, and
it has to do with factors outside his control.
It would be delightful to see this feeble attempt
at becoming the Republican nominee be so damaging
to his reputation and to his political career
that it precludes him from a viable shot in 2028.
And what I mean by that is the following.
If DeSantis becomes so unpopular by virtue
of the Anti-woke insanity battling Disney,
don't say gay. All of this different stuff.
It may lead to a damaged DeSantis, who can't
even plausibly justify a run in 2028. Up until
two weeks ago, when DeSantis announced
in that abortive Twitter spaces that
there were people saying he may be better off
waiting for 2028. Don't damage yourself now.
Don't put at risk 2028. Just wait. 2028 Trump will
be out of the way. Then you run. He'll still be,
I think, 48 at the time. But it would just be
great to see him destroy his own chances by virtue
of this absurd Anti-woke campaign. I want to
talk generally about Florida Republicans because
it's not a new thing that Florida Republicans
thought. I'm ready for the spotlight. Jeb Bush
thought he was ready for the spotlight in 2016.
In fact, his early polling wasn't bad and he kept
kept tripping all over himself. Low energy,
please clap all of that stuff. Marco Rubio,
another Florida elected official who thought
2016, this makes sense. I've got a shot.
Marco Rubio, who hears about Rubio anymore
occasionally, but Rubio and Jeb, I mean, neither
would have even a minor chance if they were to
run at this point in time. And I have to tell you,
not so much Marco Rubio, but by the standards
of Republicans, Jeb was an okay Republican,
which is probably why he got crushed in the
primaries in the same way that I've been talking
about Chris Christie as a somewhat reasonable
Republican and certainly the guy that would be
my choice if I were to vote for a Republican this
time around. Jeb was a mildly reasonable guy,
certainly mild mannered, and it was not what the
Republican Party was primed for in 2016. So is the
Sanders is destroying his political career? Maybe.
Is the Santos at risk of destroying his own shot
in 2028? Too early to say, but it would truly
be a delight to see that happen. We are going
to be hearing from you. Coming up on the program
this weekend, a number of streams that I do want
to let people know the live streams are going
to ramp up again. So many 20, 24 candidates are
regularly scheduling events now and we are going
to be covering a number of them. So make sure
you're subscribed on YouTube, make sure you're
subscribed on Twitch and all of the other places.
And so many things will be happening over the next
few months that it'll make your head spin, let's
put it that way. We'll take a very quick break.
And the Friday show continues right after this.